Всім привіт Сьогодні з Марією ми на
Херсонщині Ну а водіїв нас Таня Чорновол
ми дуже щасливі сьогодні бути в тебе
Чесно кажучи трошки засмучені що ти без
своїх уже таких культових фірмових
кисичок розцвіла спеціально нас
зустрічала Я розповіла що ви знову
заплести Це я просто дала да там волосся
трошки перепочити бо треба було там
старе волосся вичислити Да було два
місяці я тримала дуже косички дуже
зручна зачіска А тепер треба заплести по
новому зараз питає сама Ну от жінка на
війні - це унікальна абсолютна історія
тому що вона вміє її заступ
це пульт з моєї сторони Ось така червона
кнопочка її натискаєш так трошки
притримуєш і ракета полетіла після цього
цим жостіком тут такі приціл я цей
приціл повинна тримати на сілі до
попадіння ракети якщо наприклад цілях
рухається важко тримати на цілий танк
який ти підбила десь там на Київщині
Недалеко від мого села зараз прикрашає
оцей з іржавчина прикрашає Майдан там
буде такий парад
іржавої рашинської техніки і дуже
дякуємо Що ти там на своїй Тоні
допомогла цей парад організувати
з тої стона
ми так бачимо що треба виїжджати бронюки
я натискаю кнопочку присіли
ракета полетіла встали
фактично
я промазала ну перед цим перед цим ми
стріляли по нерухомим цілям теж Спасі
саме специфіцієнтів профспілкову був
якийсь такий зручний місце зручне ми в
тому селі багато чого в принципі набили
те що придумали робити парад під
питують класну ідею
дивилася всі ці фотки а я бачу там було
відео таке трейлер ви за один танк і я
почала так приглядатися до нього і в
мене просто така думка всі дома порозку
Це мій танго як 4 ракета що там зробила
що вона а потім все було на тому це не
може бути мій тато а потім така Та ні це
в принципі можна буде той так 100%.
чесно кажучи ця думка була якась така
така потішна потішна ловила себе на тому
що я беру участь в параді шляхом підбито
його підбитого танку і це в мене так
потіло
тому що там був підбитий не один це було
на Київщині але от Останні кілька
місяців важкою війни Таня в гарячій
точці на Херсонщині разом з нашими
іншими побратимами і наближає нашу
перемогу Я взагалі поймала себе на тому
що не боюся дуже багатьох тих речей які
ми не хвилювали раніше ну як я не знаю
там тих же самих змій в обмінку можуть
спати Тому тут тут зміна звичайно велика
зміна пріоритетів відбувається А є речі
які ну дуже ризиковані от на них зважає
що вона все інше Ні як би ти зараз
охарактеризувала безпекову ситуацію на
Херсонщині Ну а як тут твоя вступна себе
почуває
зараз у нас такий час непростий для
роботи тому що початок літа була наша
Ініціатива А зараз занадто багато місць
в цю досягнуто дуже багато артилерії
дуже багато боєприпасів рожик Я маю на
увазі а ми ж працюємо передком і я вам
скажу Якщо раніше Можна бути заїхати
вирити окопчик чергувати там чекати поки
щось вийде якщо почнуть накривати якщо
побачать не страшно є у хлопців то зараз
ситуація змінилася зараз
бачать одного військового починає
працювати касетні там боєприпасами
накривати посадочку інколи накривають
ніколи не бачить що просто посадка на
видноті да тому працювати стало набагато
важче але я розумієш що це треба Мислів
і порушення логістики Зараз ми це все
вистрелим і ми знову будемо підкрадатися
да тобто зараз от у нас такі от час
трошки такі депресивний то нам дуже
важко зараз працювати Ти підняла
дуже все ціна нашої майбутньої Перемоги
та ціна висока яку сьогодні Україна
платить за кожен метр української землі
ми з Марією сьогодні коли їхали до тебе
думали
що з який важкий місяць для твоєї родини
8 років тому під іловайськом загинув
Микола він коханий чоловік ми всі його
знали він ну він герой він чудово був
людина і ми усвідомлюємо що ця війна
почалася точно не сьогодні вона почалася
не в лютому вона почалася 8 років
дуже високу ціну твоя сім'я найвища
заплатила От
ти зараз
вже помстилася чи в процесі
Я дуже не люблю слова Помста Микола
загинув За Україну за майбутнє своїх
дітей за майбутнє
українців дітей за те щоб батьки не
відправляли дітей на війну оце дуже
страшно І коли я теж воюю
за Україну Я воюю за своїх дітей я воюю
за чужи
Х дітей Я воюю за батьків щоб ті не
відправляли дітей на війну я не вчуся я
завтра а не проти дійсно не ми починали
цю вільну
важливу її закінчити за за те щоб
Україна
не лишалася і була європейською і ти
знаєш Ми зараз робимо не повинна бути
якихось кровожер буде волосся да Тобто
помство - це звірячки інстинкт насправді
ні
ні світлі люди українці взагалі світлі
люди у нас солдати негроматне м'ясо воно
бережемо кожного нашого військового ми
бачимо за кожного цивільного який
потрапив під вогонь
Ну
тільки з такими почуттями
До речі перемагають скажи мені на
вцілому Як сьогодні забезпечення От якби
ти оцінила
чи є потяг чи є гроші чи є в комплекті
що воювати по-перше нас дуже добре
готують і це дуже правильно тому що коли
в тебе великий підрозділ
їжа дуже важлива це знову ж таки хлопці
і це бойові умови ми як наша в свій час
наше скликання над цим багато працювали
дуже добре що в армію постачається м'ясо
Да дуже добре що в армії постачаються
різні хороші продукти з яких ми можемо
теж маємо руки готуємо далі озброєння
дуже велика проблема в мене за ракетами
настільки велика що Це найбільше що в
мене проблема є от у мене на БМП
наприклад стоїть гаражі випущено туди
три ракету і не буде БМП і так і
потрібно випустивши одну ракету як
пощастить от пробиває вона цей бетон
далі ця струя щоб вона зруйнує БМП чи
пошкодить чи взагалі
ніякої шкоди це неправильно Так це
неправильно тому що мені підібратися до
цієї цілі Я дуже ризикую ризикують всі
мої люди знову-таки ну ну то така справа
і мені плакать хочеться коли Ворог у
відповідь нам десяток вистрілює просто
посадці просто там де ми можемо
бути навіть така справа тобто Нацгвардія
замовила А це інше Міністерство да а
Міністерство оборони Ні дуже правильне
питання - це збільшення е-е зарплати
військовослужбовцям бойові коли на
першій лінії знову таки скажу Ну як
військовослужбовець Як е-е колишній
депутат да можливо це забезпечення можна
було зробити і менше не 100 000 50 000
але давати знову таки без цих всіх
затримок щоб це було регулярно так
гроші ці доволі такі великі щоб
забезпечувати самих себе
хто відреагувати навіть ніколи але
вітергує про всякі дрібні потреби
нам треба мотоцикл Ми купуємо мотоцикл
для розвідки нам нам потрібно перфоратор
щоб у
кого попереду Ми купуємо перший раз все
це ми робимо мобільно ну такі як
зарплати ці є ми можемо собі це
дозволити і це нам дає ну
виправда ніж у нашого горла Які
наприклад собі такі речі не може
дозволити Ми дуже мобільні ми
прилаштовуємося завдяки тому що можемо
собі щось купити справді в різних
підрозділах різної інформації у десь
день день платять десь є е-е затримка і
ми з Марією і нашої команди будемо з цим
розбиратись що скажеш по зброї з перших
днів війни і не тільки з перших днів
війни хотілось би звичайно щоб
це ми не втрачали часто Які на жаль
трошки був втрачений а хмм
ми просимо гуманітарну допомогу це
тільки зброя зброя зброя зброя і
максимально щоб санкції навколо
Російської Федерації звужувалися
звужувались вони ще недостатні і ми так
само чесно говоримо про це з нашими
союзниками але саме головне те що ми вам
Дякуємо що ми можемо далі працювати щоб
ви тримаєте цей фронт і за те що ви
боретесь дійсно за майбутнє нашого
покоління і ти як Мама як дочка ну такий
теж приклад для і дівчат в тому числі ми
тут Напередодні дня незалежності І в
День Прапора день уж дуже коротко що
таке День незалежності День Прапора в
армії на фронті Так по-перше це не свято
навіть я це дуже велика відповідальність
тому що ми розуміємо що ворог зараз буде
намагатися нам зіпсувати День
Незалежності і можуть бути
наприклад якісь прориви тому
розслаблятися не будемо святкувати якраз
ці дні не будемо Але
зрозуміло що це свято яке виносимо
завжди з собою Да не потрібно для цього
якось розслаблятися День незалежності
для мене це найбільш важливе свято в
моєму в моєму житті не вітайте мене з 8
березня не вітайте мене
з незалежності України Я завжди так всім
там знайомим казала
то ми зараз проходимо Але я розумію що
ця важка дорога зараз це ж багато чого
розставила на свої місця багато було
засоромного в Головах
Зараз ми на жаль важкою ціною але почали
багато чого розуміти і в принципі я
вважаю що зараз незалежність України вже
не стоїть тут питання це мабуть перша
свято Я не завжди України коли я не
сумніваюся в Незалежності країни не
ставлю її державні що вона може ми
можемо її втратити це дуже велика честь
дійсно зустрічати День незалежності тут
Херсонщині мріємо про херсонські кавуни
які вже ось-ось сподіваємося будуть з
українцями от але очевидно що Таня
говорить про важливу річ якою дорогою
ціною сьогодні захищається Україна і
відновлюється наша територіальна
цілісність суверенітет і звільнюється
кожен метр української землі пам'ятаємо
про це
особливий абсолютно День Незалежності і
величезна подяка тим тисячам хлопців і
дівчат які боронять Україну я хочу
подякувати дуже хлопцям ви не являєте От
я зараз в чоловічому в принципі
колективі Які взагалі молодці хлопці як
такі це взагалі таке чудо Що в нашій
людській природі є чоловіки вони
молодці тобто він і фізична сила і їхня
сміливість і їхня шляхетність і те що в
них руки стоять що вони багато чого
можуть зробити
короче хлопчиків теж Момо Ба я вам кажу
листочки зору конкуренції тому що так є
це конкуренція на фронті між чоловіками
і жінками кажуть жінкам на жаль
доводиться доводиться доводити це важко
де це постійно в напрузі але хлопці Ви б
забес український хлопці це не Бест the
best the best скажи мені що з вами
кримінальними справами
ми з цього привезли тут трошки сміємося
бо ситуація системно гірше ніж при
сталінність тому що коли при сталіні
відправляли штрафбати да то вижив то все
вже гуляє у нас же зараз все навпаки мою
судовий розгляд відклали відклали до
завершення війни тобто якщо виживу
засудять і посадять
переїжджали з вами річку Коли я прийшла
на цю територію там був ворог
і була така внутрішня задача до початку
річки
[музика]
займатися спортом Короче ми звільнили
той фрагмент річки і далі Навіть трошки
звільнили це ми їхали була пряма
вигідність Раніше там їздити було не
можна було з того березня стояв ворог
Зараз ми довільно їздимо викупаєтеся
іноді іноді навіть ловити карасі
підсмажити їх але це буває не часто тому
що ну важливо смажити ворогам не
які повинні бути в армії повинна
покупатися це не будуть херсонщина
любимо дуже мріємо про те що український
прапор найкращий у світі буде в центрі
Херсону ну отакі от у нас тут польові
дороги Але Таня дивіться який
знаходиться Слава Україні Героям слава